♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est au rythme
des applaudissements
et des trompettes que
la lieutenante-gouverneure
a fait son entrée en chambre.
Dans son discours,
des références à l'inflation
et à l'incertitude économique.
Mais hormis ces quelques
phrases, les priorités
du gouvernement avaient
des airs de déjà-vu.
- It's a budget that says yes
to rebuilding Ontario's economy.
- En avril, quelques jours avant
de déclencher des élections,
présenté un budget axé
sur l'investissement
en infrastructures.
(cris et applaudissements)
aux progressistes-conservateurs
une large majorité
le gouvernement revient
à la charge en déposant
à celui du printemps.
Quelquechchangements
mineurs y ont été apportés,
comme une aide financièretststss
et les personnes en situation
h handicap.
Mais rien pour répondre
à la crise grandissante dans
les hôpitaux de la pnunununununl
a récemment forcé
la fermeture temporaire
de plusieurs urgences.
- Pour faireà cette crise, les s
réclamaient, entre autres,
une augmentation salariale,
une demande à laquelle
le gouvernement n'a pas
Entre la pénurie de personnel
dans les hgalopante, le deuxièmt
de Doug Ford commence avec
deux grandes crises à gérer.
Et même avec une majorité
à une opposition affaiblie,
le premier ministre devra
répondre à des questions
difficiles et peut-être
de ses priorités.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Toronto